HI! In this video we are going to talk about
the best hairspray for men & woman
I am Daniel and this is DLM Model Lifestyle
Let's start
If this is your first time on my channel
subsrcibe & hit the bell, so you won't miss anything
what a lot of people do not know
about hairspray is that you use it as a
finishing product
you style you hair with other products first
with mousse or pomade or wax
and once you are happy with how your hair looks
you add the hairspray at the end to keep it for the day
so it lock it in place
I like the mousse from Loreal Paris
the ever style boosting mousse
because my hair is life-less and I struggle with it
so make my hair wet, put in the mousse
the mousse gives my hair more body
then I move on to the pomade
or wax
but I like pomade more
I like the pomade from suavecito
It is an awesome product
I will add the links of all the products in the video description below
ok, so what  is the best hairspray?
There's a lot of hairspray's out there
a lot of good ones and bad ones
got2b is good
tresemme is also good
but I like  the hairspray from Tigi
the bedhead hairspray from Tigi
It will keep your hairstyle the way you want it
for the whole day
it holds any hairstyle & you only spray a little
for a long lasting effect
one bottle will last you a long time
now you know my top pick for the best hairspray for men and woman
if you liked the video, give me a thumbs up
subscribe and I will see you in the next video